welcome back everybody we're here with
Martha Stewart give it
up our next guest is simply one of the
greatest basketball players of all time
she is I'm gonna hope I get this right
she is a seven time WNBA All-Star a
three-time WNBA Champion including a
championship this year and a two-time
WBA MVP so she is really good at
basketball her new ESPN documentary is
called Candace Parker Unapologetic you
can see it on ESPN and ESPN plus
everybody give it up for Candace
[Applause]
[Music]
Parker oh my
God the height back to back and I
and I'm like I'm like in really big
heels like it's fine it's fine it's
beautiful you can reach everything on
the shelves um have y'all ever have
y'all ever met I have not no but I'm
very I'm a big fan I am a big fan of
yours I have a number of your books and
my mom is there's 100 to pick from fans
of both of you all so so so expain the
documentary why was this important for
you I think it was so important just at
that point and this point in my life um
just to show how far come in my career
but also with my family so coming off a
successful rookie season I had my
daughter uh my second year and that was
the first question was you know what
about your career and then when I'd be
on the road people would always ask me
like who's taking care of your daughter
oh my god do you ask men that and that
would be the thing I'm like do you do
you ask LeBron where his kids are no you
don't because you call that babysitting
and I'm done exactly that's how it is so
I I just noticed the difference and you
can follow your dreams and still bring
your family along
absolutely you know I find it more
powerful I find it more powerful that
you had all that weight on everybody was
like you know oh my God she's going to
be the face of and then you did do
something that was very much a feminine
thing to do we have babies and um and
it's it's a beautiful thing it's and it
what sucks for you and I just want to
apologize for humans that are um mean is
that that should have been a beautiful
time for you that should have been a
beautiful moment for you to be like
pregnant cuz you always wanted to have a
kid right always um from a young age I
was playing house I had you know four
kids all my names picked out for my kids
before they were so different
yeah I wanted to what are the names what
well my daughter's name is ilila and my
son's name is a um but at the time you
know those changed because you get a
partner and they have an opinion too and
you have to kind of compromise and I
like oh my God I guess yours I mean I
guess you get to name them too too yeah
uh but I always wanted to be a mom and
you're right and I think this time
around um when my wife and I were
expecting it was like I wanted to be
able to post pictures of her pregnant I
wanted to be able to share I'm glad to
celebrated though it makes other it
empowers other people to be able to be
able to balance both if they'd like and
to be able to balance and not worry
about what the perception is um and not
doing it you know because of others you
do it for yourself and so I think the
biggest thing with motherhood is it's
taught me to like continue to strive to
what makes me happy yeah and you know
what makes my family happy yeah and it's
so interesting too when they say oh
who's watching a child I'm like who is
watching any person's child that has a
job like you know what I'm saying
grandma and nny like some like true well
we have all dealt with divorce so what
which is horrific um what's it like for
y'all like in the public gu mine was
very public um it that's very hard cuz I
know a lot of people do a divorce even
at work and it's like you have to show
up you have to smile you have to do your
job but you know you're kind of dying
inside like how is that for
y'all no one wants this therapy session
right now yeah yeah I got divorced
during my wedding book tour oh my God
and I had to talk about weddings and
wedding dresses and how to have a
wedding what and that's when I had to
get divorced it was horrible good you
just trumped both of them you win oh my
God that must have been so hard and it
took a long time dragged out don't drag
it out that's the that's my advice yeah
don't drag it out wow well you try not
to yeah that's a hard follow yeah I feel
like my life um I'm either killing it in
the business world like and with my
purpose and my job my love um or or I'm
killing it in Romance and it's like it's
very hard to have both for me apparently
but um but how do how do you feel did do
you feel like it was a struggle cuz your
life has changed you were with a man now
you're with a woman you got to tell this
whole story like your life has changed
dramatically like that's hard to do in
general but also in the public eye
that's a lot of eyes watching and I
think sometimes you know in the
documentary I talk about how it took a
long time for me to be okay with my
journey and
myself and the understanding that not
everybody is going to love it you know
but I just ask that you respect it yeah
and so with that being said um
yeah and I think you're a better mom
because you're pursuing your goals and
your dreams and I know I'm a better mom
because I'm pursuing my dreams and I
tell my daughter that my daughter will
be like why can't you come to this
somebody else's mom comes to this I'm
like okay well I have a job and I just
want you to look at me and know that
when you grow up and you have a job you
can also have kids too and you can also
make it all happen you can balance and
you want to be there and there are
things that you have to miss yeah and
there are things my mother missed I'm
fine like I'm like everybody's got to
make everything no you don't people Miss
games people Miss performances that's
okay like you try your best but like
that's okay I hate when people are like
oh you missed that one I'm like I made
the other 10 I was like you know listen
I am not the cupcake mom like you know
the one that does all the cupcakes and
then have you seen the like viral thing
now with the lunches where they cut like
the like dinosaurs into like eggs and
all that stuff no my daughter got lucky
if like the sandwich was together you
know what I mean but she's good like you
know it's it's the the thought that
counts right you were yeah I was like
she probably did do she did the dinosaur
you did the the sh cut she's prob like
well she like I'm out at that too oh my
go did you ever feel like that you had
to pick between love and work I didn't
buy the pony I didn't buy the pony and
that that keeps haunting me oh my god
get the pony oh my God oh my God iy hope
my my daughter's not
watching Christmas is coming up Martha
said that you were going to get me a
pony Martha made history with her Sports
Illustrated Swimsuit Issue cover at 81
years
old first of all ma'am goodness every
81-year-old out there is like this is
not like the others like this is like
like it's incred why now like this is
incredible I wonder
I they never asked me before yeah I
would I would have done it when I was 40
I looked great at
40 well they think you look right at 81
too so it's it's just I love that you
you did it too I think it it was the
most popular one right of the covers
yeah we got like many many billions of
impr it was
crazy I do think though you age really
well so I don't know if that's
comparable to the rest of us but um I
don't know did your did your mother
influence you didn't she kind of
influence your attitude about aging mom
mom was great and mom was mom was
beautiful and with it and totally alert
and and intelligent and she raised six
kids no and uh and she was great until
the the day she passed away at 93 so
she's a and she never sick and she was
uh she was fantastic she was swimming
every day you know she's an amazing
woman what a great role model as well
very good role model well you were
following in those footsteps yeah I was
like wow so um I don't know do you feel
like with age like people get put in
boxes whether it's in the industry I'm
sure they do as well in sports like do
you feel that I feel like to some extent
like the world likes putting women
especially in boxes yeah and then
getting mad when they don't fit in the
box that they put them in yeah and I
think the limitations that they put on
you and what you're capable of I'm 6'4
and when I was younger I didn't want to
play I'm short no that's what I thought
that's why I wanted to play point guard
and everybody was like no you have to
stand by the basket and you know shoot
Hooks and do all that and for me it was
like I really loved Allen Iverson he was
my favorite player growing up right yeah
and my dad was like go dribble like Go
pass and I think now we're seeing the
value of being versatile and playing
different positions but yeah of course
the world puts limitations on you and I
think it's just your job to kind of be
like whatever right no yeah say no thank
you n nah just a n a um so why have you
chosen against retiring you said you
were going to retire right well first
okay I've been pondering retirement from
basketball at like 34 35 36 37 how old
are you I'm 37 right now still pondering
pondering retirement but what's crazy is
now my teammates are closer to my
daughter's age than my age so they're
over there doing Tik toks and I'm like
what are y'all doing like how do you
know all of these dances and these dance
moves and I'm like Grandma on the team
that's like wait what's the lyric to
that song you're singing what like
that's me in the locker room so you're
only 37 but it's it's coming cuz it the
it when I started realizing T don't Tic
Tac Toe whatever it's called T Tik toac
don't matter it's how you play on the on
on yeah it's how you play on the court
it's true but when you start seeing that
your daughter is having more in common
with your teammates than you are you're
like wow this is is your daughter going
to play she plays volleyball and
basketball oh yeah and she loves yeah
she loves basketball I didn't know this
but some WNBA players they have to get
second jobs because they don't the pay
yeah is that still like happening hard
100% uh for the first 10 years of my
career I went from April to October in
the WBA and from October to April
overseas so I played in Russia I played
in Turkey I played two years in China
and my daughter was a five-month-old
baby packed her up 12 bags went to
Russia yeah um that was what and still
is the reality of a lot of WNBA players
and you know I think it's just important
to understand that like when that you
know corporations organizations they put
women on television women's sports I
mean now everybody's catching up but
it's been a thing it's just that the
visibility wasn't there and so now I
think the more visibility that women
sports has the more sponsorship
exactly it's going to happen yeah cuz
that's insane the difference between men
and women uh we need a commercial break
everybody check out the world of Martha
on Amazon for all your holiday
entertaining needs as well as the best
in kitchen and dining feding and bath
and furniture and Home Decor everything
under the umbrella and don't miss
Candace Parker Unapologetic on ESPN and
ESPN
[Music]
Plus
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home